joining us now from NBC sports Boston we
sent up the signal for him knowing that
Tom Brady would be newsworthy and sure
enough that actually happened Tom Curren
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
there's a signal Tom Curren joining me
here on the Rich Eisen show the day that
Tom Brady says his farewells via
Instagram to the New England Patriots
Tom house New England taking it so far
rich New England weeps and I am not in a
good spot
so was at the moment I will be in a
great spot in about 14 seconds okay okay
fine let me tap dance for 10 seconds Tom
Curren clearly on a daily commute where
he knows that there's a dead spot for a
phone call and we all know it we all
deal with it we all got it back so when
you say when you say New England weeps
what do you mean by that Tom very much
been a reluctance and denial that
whether it's me or Jeff Darlington or
anyone looking on this or the course of
time I mean I wrote December that unless
there was a radical course change wrote
about 2,000 words on it that Tom Brady
was going to be a free agent and I got
hooted pretty resoundingly by most
Patriots fans as being doom and gloom
and partaking in hotcakes and just
looking for quicksand it's sadly I mean
I've covered the team for a long time I
don't want Tom Brady to go anyplace I
grew up here
it's been fun I don't want to see the
Jarrett's to damira but I think so many
people have tamp down the reality of the
situation and believed or preferred to
believe that everything between Tom and
Bill has always been terrific and every
time they even stare at each other it's
supposed to be a rebuttal that this even
anything untoward between them in terms
of a philosophical difference it's not
true
they have a deep philosophical eyed on
how to proceed the atmosphere wasn't
what Grady was enjoying bill is over the
course of time rich
despite the fact we sat in the room with
him I found now to me I just used that
in a story actually sorry
here but go for it you know as you saw
as you saw bill and Tom across the table
from you and I watched it on TV it
reminded me just of how much Tom really
covets the validation of Bill and how
much as he spoke about how Peyton
Manning had so much control with be
annapolis Colts from the Denver Broncos
Brady said I've never had that how much
he felt as if his relationship with Bill
was always going to be coach employee
even after 20 years bill was not going
to deviate from that and he was never
gonna get the bouquets verbally or
otherwise rhodium because enough other
people were doing that and Bill's mind
the time didn't need it from Bill too
but maybe he did four of all the
anecdotes for it for Tom Brady to seize
upon the one from the day after Super
Bowl 36 for Belichick turns Tillman says
you had a pretty good season yes it's
funny and yes it is indicative of who
bill is but the fact that Tom holds on
to that keeps in his pocket and rolls it
around in the palm of his hand
remembering it says something as well so
when it all came down to it after 20
years Tom doesn't want to be with Bill
anymore essentially is what you're
saying is how this all played out over
the last two weeks two months two years
I mean timeline all this for me is where
in showing on our youtube comrade slash
Rich Eisen show feed a you know the very
flowery for certainly for him statement
from Bill Belichick and obviously Robert
Kraft from the Patriots today Tom
finally threw his hands up and said I'm
going to stop looking for the hug and
the commitment that I've been dying to
get from this person in this team in
this organization that I feel that I
have that I deserve so while and I know
Robert Kraft has framed it today at
least in other conversations I spoke to
him and he did not frame it this way
with me but did frame it as if this is
Tom's decision well as I wrote earlier
his decision to leave is the same as
yours and my decision to get out of the
car after it's part of the driveway put
in park and the engines turned off
there's really nothing else you can do
but get out I mean that's that's it the
rides over Tom I think it's had that
made very clear to him in 2017 when he
asked for an extension prior to the
trade of Jimmy Garoppolo certainly after
the three to Cuba Garoppolo window
extension came and instead they were
just incentives of which treaty it done
then prior to the 2019 season again
asking for an extension same thing is
true a breeze being told that he'd
probably get that the two years twenty
five million dollars a year deal and
then instead getting nothing to the
point we were braiding it and intimated
that you know what I might be walking
out of camp here and then they gave him
a raise so those were the elements that
led Tom Brady to decide to leave so was
it his decision or was it just okay why
would I continue to wait I mean did the
Patriots expect Tom Brady
to legitimately open negotiations with
them because that seems to be what they
were intimating that they thought he was
supposed to tell them what he wanted
when he was the free agent so I don't
see that as the Tom Brady's decision I
see that as him reading the writing on
the wall and saying okay well I'm gonna
head out now they go okay we're gonna
see him we love this this was great yes
it was well I guess rubber now Tom I
mean just just I guess to throw in
perspective from my own you know
universe you know I when I started at
ESPN I thought I'd be there forever
literally it was my identity it was the
the the people who I was literally I
came from the Northern California screw
it I'll complete the the analogy
graduated from Michigan was working in
Northern California at a small-market
station in Redding California I was like
pick 199 you know like they yes PM found
me there and and gave me a platform and
gave me a career and gave me an
opportunity in which I tried to be as
great as I possibly could I was a
competitive son-of-a-bitch
right now I just said those words you
know so but I parted ways because
circumstances were created by management
that left me no choice in my mind but to
leave you know and I think that's what
you're saying right now yes yes but did
you decide to leave after it was made
clear to you that you weren't part of a
long term solution perhaps I don't know
what your situation was right
I think the tom has felt as if look I'm
just I'm human duct tape here I got six
Super Bowls I throw up a 505 against the
Eagles we went another one last year and
the next thing I know I show up for camp
not only do I have no raise but I'm
throwing the gun all chefs came to Colby
Meyers and I know by the end of the year
after we have an ask year of statistics
that they're gonna look at me and say we
can't give you any more money
so what's he supposed to do go get an
offer from Tampa Bay run back to the
Patriots and say there are from you
twenty nine million dollars a year for
the next three years what do you think
and they tell them then bill says yeah
good for you no just I try and make it
as the amicable as possible today I
think that I really hope that happens
even though this industry doesn't really
want to allow that to happen
but I just hope it can be imitable
philosophical differences well I mean
Bella checks last line of a statement
was exactly what your you're saying I
guess he didn't say enough of where he's
he said sometimes in life it takes some
time to pass before truly appreciating
something or someone but that has not
been the case with Tommy's a special
person and the greatest quarterback of
all time it sounds like you're saying
you didn't hear that enough forever is
that what you said you know if he said
stuff like that more frequently he
wouldn't be leaving now again and I've
said this a number of times to folks
here and maybe on this show as well
there are folks around Tom who I think
sometimes get emotional and light
overstate so I tamp down sometimes what
their statements are I don't know if
that would be the case or not
if bill told them every day with notes
in his lunch that you're the greatest
quarterback of all time it's
any different or not but it is what he
kind of sought was just hey you know we
look look he might be the greatest
quarterback of all time but this bill
thing she's gonna be the greatest
quarterback at 25 million dollars a year
with 13 and a half billion dollars in
debt money in 2020 I don't think so all
right before I let you go then Tom
what's the plan be as you have pointed
out the Patriots clearly have seen the
possibility of this happening they sense
it they had to know it and Belichick is
not a guy that isn't prepared to the
enth degree into his teeth so what is
the plan be here now is it is it going
into the season with Jared Stidham
drafting somebody signing somebody in
free agency what do you think for me or
trading for somebody there's cam there's
Andy Dalton potentially I mean what's
the plan B my reflexes anticipate what
the hell reflective incident you see
what you expect expect to happen really
I mean bring me Andy Dalton to do what
so to put your hands at ten and two and
keep you in between the white lines I
mean it's not gonna win you games and if
it's gonna cost ten twelve thirteen
million dollars to do it you add on
Brady's money to this that's two or
three other good players you could
probably get have or renegotiate so go
ahead with chair instead of now I could
be wrong they might go got and when we
talk about bills planning it is
generally exquisite but that doesn't
explain why there's no tight end from a
roster for the last five years either
and why no tight end succession plan was
a place for Rob Gronkowski could see
that coming too so I don't know where
they're gonna go I do they know they
still have the best head coach the NFL
and the best culture for winning in the
NFL but I think it's gonna be it's gonna
be a tough road and they have a lot of
work ahead of them the terms of
rebuilding the entire roster and in
terms of that Kyle van Noy ZnO a dolphin
he hit it big and is to knee there to
stay what do you think is happening
right now franchised to keep him off the
market from teams who would otherwise
try and grab him ie the Jets keep him in
New England make sure you work out a
long-term deal drop his cap number but I
do not think that he was signed to the
franchise tender an order to trade okay
and the poll question ask it of Tom e
Curran of NBC Sports Boston Christopher
go for it
Tommy I'm so sad who wins I know it
sucks how who ends the AFC East this
year yeah bill you believe so huh really
Tom really really yeah I mean Stefon
Diggs Boston not I know right yeah no no
no and then you got the Singletary and
obviously Josh Allen in year three this
is this is Dermot can coach this could
be really happening right now a changing
of the guard in the AFC East is that
really what's happening to the call
appreciate it you take care no no things
change very fast I may be calling you
literally tonight to say how about
tomorrow or Thursday come on now let's
be honest all right take care of
yourself you go that's Tom Curren that's
a NBC Sports Boston check him out on his
podcast as well